hubo actividad en el baloncesto voleibol
de campo ecuestre y se entregaron nuevas
preseas en la esgrima y también en el
ciclismo de ruta que tuvo la prueba
contrarreloj tanto individual como en
masculino precisamente en esta
especialidad en esta modalidad de
masculino walter ramos de colombia'
cubrió la ruta de poco más de 39
kilómetros en un tiempo de 47 minutos un
poco más de 47 minutos para él y se
quedó con la presea dorada mientras
tanto que entre las damas fue la
ecuatoriana miriam núñez quien se quedó
con la presea dorada esta vez es
superando a una de las favoritas como lo
es esférica cullum más de colombia
quedando en el segundo lugar el tercer
lugar fue para lilibeth chacón especial
atención no tuvo miriam núñez al momento
de consagrarse como la nueva campeona
bolivariana del ciclismo de pista en la
modalidad contrarreloj con sus pares en
quitó por la situación que atraviesa
este país escuchemos
y lamentablemente el país está pasando
por una crisis y bueno algunos de mis
compañeros tuvieron que llegar
al aeropuerto a la capital en bici
pasando 5 o 6 horas y creo que todo esto
y esta medalla también es por el equipo
que está acá por los muchachos dice que
ellos también van a hacer una bonita
actuación
juan recientemente también en culminaron
las pruebas de esgrima en la modalidad
de sable individual del femeninos ya
rodríguez se colgó la medalla dorada
esta vez venciendo a heidi valentín de
república dominicana en un combate que
terminó 15 por 9 también medalla de oro
para venezuela en la espada masculina a
través de gabriel lugo quien venció a
jhon rodríguez de colombia 15 13 un
combate muy disputado en la ciudad de
valledupar